when a user discovers a new favorite
song or news article in your app they
may want to share it with their friends
you can allow users to generate a
Google+ post that includes a deep link
that takes them directly to that piece
of content within your website Android
or iOS app if the user doesn't have your
app they're taken to the google play or
the Apple App Store where they're
encouraged to install it here's an
example of deep link sharing on Android
from pulse news when they click the
button a google+ share box opens and the
user shares the article with their
friends as you'd expect clicking the
post takes friends to the pulse app and
directly to the piece of content to take
advantage of deep links make sure that
each of your clients is defined in the
same API console project this way we
know the right app to launch on the
platform that you're using when your app
creates a post that contains a deep link
you set the content URL and the deep
link ID that post shows up on Google+ on
web or mobile the content URL is not
only where we direct users that click on
the post but is also the source from
which Google populates the post preview
content the deep link ID on the other
hand is an opaque strength which can
contain any information your app needs
to read the user to the right content
using the google plus mobile SDKs you
can help your users share the content
they like most within your app check out
our developer Docs to learn more about
deep links on Android and iOS